dernier entraînement pour l'équipe de
france masters ce avant les championnats
du monde les pistards âgés de plus de 35
ans ont pu mettre en place l'aide
technique au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en vue de la
compétition qui se tiendra à partir de
ce samedi jusqu'au dimanche 8 octobre à
manchester en angleterre
normalement le groupe est prêt
normalement voilà ces sont les derniers
réglages à effectuer vu que comme on
vous disait tout à l'heure ils viennent
de toute la france
on a des aquitains on a des gens de
bretagne voilà donc il faut faire les
réglages particulièrement pour les
épreuves par équipes
l'entraînement des dix coureurs s'est
déroulée sous les yeux du parrain de la
section masters
quant à la fargue champion de france de
vitesse 2015 et double médaillé de
bronze aux championnats du monde et
c'est d'essayer de leur faire profiter
de mon expérience du haut niveau actuel
pour pour voilà alors permettre de les
aider à avancer après on a chacun nos
calendriers et je suis pas ultra présent
il raterait l'emploi mais mais
je trouve que voilà ils s'organisent ils
s'organisent pas mal et puis cette team
ces petits malades la gueule quand même
aux derniers championnats du monde la
france avait décroché trois médailles
dont un titre en individuel
le team master's espère améliorer cette
performance cette année en terre
britannique